ملاعب السعوديه تلفت الانظار في اسيا 2017
ويبقيه في السجن الارجنتيني فرنانديز
يحرموا زياش من اللاعب لسان جيرمان هذه
الاخبار وغيرها نقدمها لكم من العربيه
رياضه اهلا بكم
[موسيقى]
في السعوديه 2017 عن كل التجهيزات التي
شهدتها الملاعب في كل المناطق لاستضافه
لكاس امم اسيا وتضمن الملف وتطوير استاد
الملك فهد الذي شهداء رفع عدد المقاعد
وازاله المضمار بينما سيشهدوا ملعب الامير
فيصل بن فهد في وسط الرياض ازاله المضمار
وزيادتها طاقه الاستيعابيه بينما تميز سد
الدمام بمواصفات حديثه وبيئه محفزه لتحقيق
مشاهده ممتعه للجميع سيتم تاخير استاذ
مدينه الامير سعود بن جوي تاهيلا متكاملا
وكذلك الساده الامير محمد بن فهد الذي شهد
او سيشهده عمليه تجديد هي الاولى منها
طلب ابدا يا قلبي ايش من المحكمه الافراج
عنهم مؤقتا متعهدا بعدم مغادره اسبانيا
لكن القاضي رفض طلبه
ان يهرب البرازيلي والناتي الى البرازيل
عفوانا والتي لا يوجد لا يوجد بها
المجرمين المدافع والسابق لبرشلونه
ويوفنتوس ومنتخب البرازيل يخضع للتحقيقات
بشان
تتعلق بالاعتداء الجنسي على امراه في ملهى
الليلي في اسبانيا الشهر الماضي كان يلبس
ينفجر كتابه
الفقه تشيلسي اوراقا خاطئه في اخر لحظه في
سوق الانتقالات الشتويه ليرفض انتقال
المغربي حكيم زياش بالاعاره الى باريس سان
جيرمان نادي الفرنسي رفع احتجاجا لدى
الاتحاد المحلي يطلب فيه مهله اضافيه
لتصحيح الخطا وفي ظل استياء اداره نيسان
جرمان من الخطا كشفت مصادره ان السبب في
ذلك هو ان مسؤوليه بلوس كانوا مركزين بشكل
اكبر على اتمام صفقه الارجنتيني فرناندو
فنان ديزل الذي ضمه في اخر دقائق الشتويه